we will deal honestly with the american
people
and we'll never ever ever quit
that's how we'll shut down this virus
i'm going to shut down the virus i'm not
going to shut down the economy i'm going
to shut down the virus
let's open up outnumbered chris bradford
you got to wonder how he's going to be
able to pull this off harris how he was
ever going to shut down the virus i know
they took a break from trying to control
the global climate but that's this seems
even a stretch by that the problem i
think that we're facing here is a lot of
covet really at this point is a social
construct when it comes down to testing
when it comes down to contamination when
it comes down to lockdowns if we track
any other communicable disease in the
same way that we track covert whether
it's you have to be isolated your family
has to be isolated you have to be going
through these tests i think there would
be a panic all the time we're not going
to get rid of this disease but the
people who are pushing this especially
where i live where you live they are so
wedded to the idea of these lockdowns
these mass mandates these school
shutdowns they've they've never worked
they're embarrassed by that they can't
admit it so they're doing it again we
just started the new mask mandate here
this morning in dc dc public schools
just announced that they will be
shutting down again none of this has
ever worked it's hurting children it's
hurting businesses it's hurting america
but if they won't let go of that and
follow the cues of say ron desantis
who's actually trying to help the people
of his state
then they're never going to get anywhere
in florida by the way has a very low
covert rate i know people like to say
this because they're outside i just got
back from florida those bars and
restaurants and concerts are packed
indoors but they've got a different
strategy of dealing with it and because
of that the panic has actually gone away
so what's interesting about some of what
chris is saying kaylee is you know with
regard to what we learned some people
some governors some states learned from
the last two years
not so convinced some of the american
people say that the president and other
democrat states did learn but new jersey
is a cobalt blue state our governor
murphy there not doing the lockdowns
he's not following these east coast
governors anymore
we don't have any of that and and we can
get monoclonal antibodies and we can get
those things that we saw down in florida
it's interesting
it is interesting and you see red state
governors like desantis doing a
fantastic job chris bedford is right i'm
a floridian i've seen it firsthand
there's a balance between freedom
and between coveted restrictions and he
seemed to have found that balance and
the numbers bear out he's done quite a
good job also i want to lay the foot of
blame out of a lot of this at the seat
of the federal government i talked to
someone who was a high level official
that i worked for in the federal
government and i said explain to me what
is going on right now explain this to me
because when we were there i remember i
saw these officials come and sit down
with me and say down to the hospital
level county not county level hospital
level we're able to see what supplies
they have what they don't work with the
private sector and surge supplies okay
well what's the difference between what
happened then what happened now
key to making sure that tests are being
produced is communicating with the
private sector which the trump
administration did daily abbot who we
know has that rapid test about i was
told june july stopped producing this
rapid test at the scale needed because
they were not receiving communication
from the federal government where
president trump purchased 500 million
500 million abbott tests giving a signal
produce produce produce the biden
administration i was told to this day
has not done that so when you're not
surging money when you're not giving an
indicator to the private sector we will
get these tests we will distribute them
you have a problem and why are we
sitting here in december december and
now biden's saying i'm going to purchase
tests i'm going to communicate with the
private sector he had 12 months to
continue the good work of the trump
administration it did not uh 12 months
by your by your source that formal trump
former trump official but at least six i
mean i look at our state of new jersey
you can call the hotline you can go on
the website you can get a home test into
you any as many as you need in your
household you've been able to do that in
several states i mean the white house is
behind it now they're expected to
announce that 500 million haul
of tests that can be sent to your home
now
but it's supply chain crisis holiday
season i mean everything takes a little
bit of time is he going to come to my
house with it in his pocket
maybe amazon's got a deal because
they're the fastest in the business look
i'm being honest here like he's behind
the times and kaylee you got some of the
receipts for that kennedy
yeah and and by the way this virus is
having its way with people it is
mutating i know that joe biden wants to
take it behind the woodshed and punch it
in the face
but that's not necessarily happening now
and
i i would like more
doctors to be honest about what's
happening here because
there is an inverse proportion between
transmissibility and death the more
transmissible the virus is the more
people who get it the more contagious it
is it looks as though and we're seeing a
lot of research like this out of south
africa uh more people are getting it
younger people are getting it but their
symptoms are not nearly as bad as they
were in spring of last year that's good
news and it also means that the virus
can shift from a pandemic to an endemic
which means it's something that will
always be with us that is more
manageable but you know to kaylee's
point the federal government has to get
out of the way if they are not helping
and you know right now not only are we
hearing about low orders we're also
hearing about supply chain backlogs on
some of the testing equipment exactly
that's another reason you're seeing such
long lines at testing facilities and
what about this kennedy because i know
you've been interviewing on your program
doctors mccary and siegel and others as
well i enjoy talking with the doctor ja
as well whenever we can can make the
time with for each other um and and so
you talk about supply chain issues
they're big on that pill especially
siegel they're big on that pfizer pill
because that puts another therapeutic in
there where is biden on this issue is he
going to announce that there'll be
expeditious delivery is he going to push
the fda to not take it as long as it did
to even get to the point where that was
mainstreamed for the for the vaccines
where we could get them and it wasn't
always an emergency authorization
yeah and that's a great point that's
another thing you know when i talk about
the federal government getting out of
the way get the fda out of the way stop
stepping all over your own message and
just make sure that this therapeutic can
get in the bodies of sick people because
it is the thing that is keeping people
in the hospital from dying you know
that's in addition to the vaccine and
all the science we have uh that
corrected some of the stuff about
barriers and and things that were
superfluous that weren't helping us that
pill will save lives bottom line so get
that emergency authorization please or
at least push for it i mean tommy i hear
you know the white house will say well
it's not our position to tell agencies
what to do
um well they can suggest can't they i
mean a suggestion from the white house
has to mean something well unless it
comes to build back better maybe not
then
that's very interesting because they
don't want to tell agencies what to do
but they have no problem telling the
american people what they should do you
know we know that we're going to hear
from president biden a stark warning for
the unvaccinated but i'd also like to
point out in the midst of also a supply
chain crisis but we've got hospitals now
they're worried about them being
overwhelmed let's not forget it was this
administration that was pressuring those
health care workers to get vaccinated or
else be terminated so now we're going to
be in a position where we might have
long lines at hospitals who might be
short staffed at hospitals like we are
everywhere else in this country and you
had an administration that was
threatening to terminate those very
people that are essential that we very
much need not only for omicron and for
kobe but for everything else so let's
keep that in mind but i agree with
kennedy we should not be pegging our
lockdowns and our mandates and our
restrictions on case totals we should be
pegging them on mortality and death
rates if we've got something that we're
living with that is highly transmissible
but the symptoms are mild and it's not
killing people at the rate that we saw
with the earlier versions of cobit well
then that in itself is an accomplishment
so we should be moving forward with life
understanding we're going to have to
live with covid stop bullying the
american people into doing what this
administration feels is best start
giving people liberty and personal and
medical freedom and let's move on with
our lives yeah we're never going to get
to zero cobid we're never going to get
to zero stupidity we're never going to
get to zero anything but those types of
goals for learning to live with things
that's what we do with other diseases